and here we are baseball together
every seat
available
100
capacity
for white sox baseball
a first place team on june the 25th
start number 13. he's looking for his
seventh win he is era just wonderful at
183. you see a lot of strikeouts very
few walks gonna use that four seamer but
the slider is great and if he throws one
down and away he's gonna get him
two and two
struck him out of fastball upstairs one
gone
that is a shattered back
and tim awaits the arrival of out number
two one and two to count on seeger
here's the pitch
swing and a miss strike three you say
kakuchi has really been pitching well as
of late it'll be a 14 start 4-3 record
of 3-4-6 era
and 80 and two-thirds he has 81
strikeouts over 26 walks
the pause the pitch
swinging a ground ball it is skimming
over jp crawford mariner shortstop picks
it up throws high
france leaps he makes the catch and he
falls right back down on the bag just in
time
0-2 pitch
strike 3 call boy making it look easy
against goodwin just dots the lower
outside edge
here's the 1-1
swinging this is clubbed high out to
left field but not nearly deep enough
right there to make the catch is bowers
for out number three now the side
retired in order very quickly by you say
kikuchi we go to the second scoreless
one out one on luis terrence
jumped at a high breaking ball hit it a
long way towards the gap getting up and
gone
two run homer luis terrence continues
his hot hitting his fourth consecutive
game with a base hit home run number
seven rbi 16 and 17 early lead for the
mariners
181 battingham
slider carlos a little hop in his step
that's where he wanted to put it and two
down
jp
takes time here
runaway
jazz batting right-handed he had the
go-ahead homer off the bench tuesday
night in pittsburgh
oh yes lays into a cutter
wow that is hammered out of here when he
knows it he is right a hundred percent
of the time kikuchi gives up a lot of
home runs and that was a blast almost
440 feet
2-2 yes sir slider outside corner one
goal
and that one had
the whole corner
good pitch
off the end of the battle squibber
that's gonna work
and erase the third rodon covering to no
avail nice set up here for the mariners
smother that slider
check swing
he did go phil cousy rings up murphy to
goa murphy can't believe it he's
incredulous he's aghast there's bowers
now with two outs runners on the corners
swung on ground ball sharply hit into
right field for a base hit ty france
will score kyle seeger will hold up at
second base and jake bowers coming
through with two outs in the third
inning the mariners tack on one more it
is three to one m's
struck him out slider away
six strikeouts for rodon but a 3-1
deficit
and seen that sign from murph before
he does it when he wants the high
fastball from him
[Applause]
right to dylan moore
line drive two down
oh good heat at 97.
third strikeout he's got a 3-1 lead
[Music]
this to right and garcia
dives leori garcia
he gets great outfield jumps that was
another one
well that was really a terrific play i
mean look this is a guy that plays all
positions he's not an outfield
specialist
[Applause]
good pitch by kikuchi fourth strikeout
the 1-1
swinging a ground ball over to crawford
chance for two slings over to dylan
moore for one on to first base and
plenty of time for the double play to
put the brakes on the fourth that'll end
things
soon he's got on on two again
it's a fastball and it's strike three so
murphy
didn't like the czech swing strike three
last time
he's got an argument on a rare miss
tonight for corey blazer one and two
from rodon
two on two out
he got him with a slider
one and two
have to get one
and they do another nice play jp
crawford
swinging on this big strikeout 2-2
3-1 mariners
jake fraley who walked his first time
breaking ball hit a long way right field
and look it up garcia there it goes the
two red homer jake fraley it's now 5-1
mariners for jake his fifth home run rbi
17 and 18 get it on a 3-2 pitch
get the other way opportunity for two
there's one jp back yes sir
two out for monkato
all four third walk in four batters in
the inning and now abreu
high fly ball long run for henniger
makes the play and that'll do it
here's terrence he homebird is first
time here's the 2-2
swung on lifted to right field this is
hit well back is garcia looking up and
it's gone into the mariners bullpen luis
terence has struck again his second home
run of the ball game a two-run swat and
the mariners extend the lead seven to
one m's
that's hit hard one hop to anderson
throws over safe run scores 8-1 mariners
for the rest of the year there's some
sparks between those guys
base hit to right garcia charges
they're going to wave around france
and he is stonewalled at the plate the
game of tag is on and he is out
two and one do you want
right side and through that's a base hit
eight to two
second run
eight to three
still nobody out in the eighth inning
okay
let's see
is mariner bullpen up and going
he got one did get the uniform now
two on nobody out
1-0
round ball france is one
j.p back to montero 3-6-1 double play
struck him out needed it and got it
two and two
that's working right there base hit
vaughn
will not get dylan moore 9-1 make that
9-3 mariners
3-2 pitch
and he does
and that roar was worth it 9-3 final
mariners good start to this road trip a
9-3 win over the white sox